this planet what's it called
trenzalore
hey youtubers it's Charlie welcome to my
second ask emergency Q&A session this
time it'll be all about Doctor Who every
week I pick a topic and then choose 10
of your questions to answer in a video
my next Q&A will be a Walking Dead
edition so be sure to leave me questions
in the comments number one here we go
ten or more asks what about when Paul
McGann regenerated he would have gotten
a whole new cycle wouldn't he PS love
your vids thank you so much you're
awesome
so what you're asking is is when Paul
McGann drank the elixir and regenerated
into the war doctor he got a whole new
cycle of regeneration that did not
happen he actually just used a normal
regeneration what the elixir does is it
just aids and very difficult
regenerations or allows a person or a
gal fran to choose what they're going to
become next question number 2 gaming
squirtle awesome name asks in the name
of the doctor the great intelligence
states that the doctor will take on the
name the valued at some time in the
future do you think the Peter Capaldi's
doctor could be the valued as he is
supposed to be playing a darker version
of the doctor so Peter Capaldi is just
the next doctor what the value art is is
he's an amalgam of the final version of
the doctor so that would basically imply
that doctor who's going to be ending
after Peter Capaldi is doctor as a
writer it's almost like giving someone
the middle finger it's like saying this
is the last time you're ever gonna see
this character question number three
John Smith asks who is the main villain
of the Christmas special so obviously
the biggest villain is the silence the
organization but there's the Daleks the
Sontarans the weeping angels the
Cybermen so there's a lot of people
Tasha LEM has like an eye stalk sticking
out of her it looks like she might be a
human form Dalek so technically it could
be the Daleks that are actually leading
this fight number four Mattie 1304 asks
have you heard about the impossible
planet that looks just like Alf ray so
yes there is a new planet that's
orbiting its own star that they found
somewhere else it's not in our solar
system obviously but it resembles
Gallifrey basically so people are
petitioning they're using change.org to
petition the International astronomers
Union to change the name to Gallifrey
because typically when they find planets
they just give them this long string of
numbers until the person that finds it
names it so if you ever find a planet
that looks like Gallifrey you have the
rights to name it number five
Jack O'Connor asks do you want to see
River Song return again I think her
storyline is over as awesome as Alex
Kingston was that series 7 finale was
kind of meant to be Matt Smith the 11th
doctor or the doctor in general
depending on how you look at it his
goodbye to River Song remember she was
actually like a spirit in that episode
she wasn't alive that being said there
will be some characters from series 5 6
& 7 that will survive into series 8 like
the Paternoster gang number 6 Adam nor
Chen asks how long will Clara be a
companion so Jenna Louise Coleman right
now is only signed on through series 8
she hasn't signed up for series 9 yet we
probably won't find out about that till
next year
number 7 Tweety two-on-two asks do you
count John Hurt as the ninth doctor
that would mean Cris as the tenth David
as the eleventh in matters of 12th yes I
do count him as the ninth but that being
said Stephen Moffat said that they're
basically going to keep the same naming
convention so Matt Smith will always be
referred to as 11 Peter Capaldi will be
referred to as 12 but in actuality their
numbers are a little bit different
number eight fullmetal venom asks what
about Neil Gaiman theory the twelve
regenerations are like a speed limit you
can break the limit but then you get
reprimanded by the police this is
actually a really good theory obviously
Neil Gaiman has written Doctor Who
before but Stephen office still does
keep things like this Christmas
regeneration secret from people like
Neil Gaiman even though he's super
famous if you ever saw the TV movie
there's actually this interesting line
about 12 being a law but the master
never really caring for rules meaning
that he was intending to regenerate past
that being said Gallifrey is stuck in a
pocket universe so they would not be
able to enforce that rule but based on
Neil Gaiman's theory there are just
certain consequences that we might not
be able to foresee from going past that
limit series 8 in series 9 will probably
deal with some of those consequences of
breaking the rule of 12 number 9 broach
games HD asks why does the doctor look
older in the trailer so what you're
asking about is Matt Smith in old age
makeup in the trailer so because the
doctors in a time dilation field he ages
much faster meaning he gets older so
Time Lords can age if you remember
during the night of the doctor when Paul
McGann regenerated into John Hurt he was
actually a young John Hurt you kind of
briefly saw his reflection so the John
Hurt we saw in the 50th is actually a
much older version like he'd been alive
and fighting the time war for a long
long long time so the same thing is
going to
and in the Christmas special that being
said we don't know if it's gonna be that
old age that causes Matt Smith to
regenerate or it's going to be something
else that actually kills him number 10
no code Lance asks what time is this
special going to air on BBC America so
it's gonna be on December 25th at 9:00
p.m. that's Eastern Standard Time if you
live in Great Britain or you're on
general standard time it's going to be
at 7:30 p.m. on bbc1 and it's only a
one-hour special unlike the David
Tennant Christmas special where he
regenerated so this is a lot of fun
thank you so much you guys for
submitting your questions remember my
next Q&A will be a Walking Dead edition
be sure to subscribe to get that and
send me your questions you can message
me on social or you can write below in
the comments just make sure you let me
know what the question is and which Q&A
it's going to be for my next Q&A after
Walking Dead is probably gonna be a
personal one so you can ask me questions
about how I make videos I know a lot of
you have asked me to do a draw your life
so it shouldn't be too long before that
happens right now you can click here to
get my breakdown of the Christmas
special careful there are plot spoilers
and you can click here to get my review
of the mid-season finale of arrow season
2 there was some awesome stuff that
happened we got to see the flash for the
first time thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you